welcome back democrats now trying to
make the midterms all about the supreme
court ruling on abortion
this fall roe is on the ballot
personal freedoms are on the ballot to
me the answer is simple it's november
it's the ballot box making roe versus
wade the law of the land that's what
november will be all about but make no
mistake
again
it's all on the ballot in november
well you know i don't blame them katie i
mean the the economy is in the crapper
they got a president who can't complete
a sentence you got criminals who don't
complete their sentences so why not you
know put that all your money on killing
unborn children yeah
that's what they're trying to hold on to
i think this is going to fall flat
because
they're making the argument that this is
on the ballot and you need to elect more
democrats democrats are in charge right
now they voted on a pro-abortion bill
earlier this year that failed because it
was so extreme and was
would allow partial birth abortion
and late-term abortion across the
country and they dishonestly said it
would codify roe when it really expanded
bro so i'm not really sure the argument
of we're in charge
haven't done this yet but give us more
seats i don't know yeah you know jessica
we saw this year the democrats going
after parents calling them domestic
terrorists we saw these horribly almost
nearly violent school board meetings
which were terrible now that you're
going to go after unborn children
jessica is the democratic party no
longer the party for families
i don't think that we were ever a party
for families no we were but that's you
guys you have do you have to it's
conservative yes or no jessica
i object i want to say something
so there's
when the leak happened conservatives
only focused on the leak they didn't
actually want to talk about the
implications of this and i think that
there will be a lot of republicans out
there especially in purplish districts
people who had uh people that supported
them in 2016 but then voted for biden
out there where this ruling will matter
so there is a way to capitalize on it
that way and that's what i would prefer
to say what do you make of this martha
we haven't talked about you know
but i do have a new thought yes on this
and it is it is that i think that katie
is right one of the things that happened
with the leak it came out earlier it
sort of defused the acceptance and
understanding over a longer period of
time and i think that the people who are
fired up on cable news networks about
this are do not actually represent the
rest of the country absolutely like i
said before abortion's been declining
it's down 20 in the last 15 15 to 20
years and also with these
over-the-counter medications that can
end up presidency quickly it is not the
issue that it once was and i think with
dana's great point about hispanic vote
family vote the democrats are fee there
are so in such trouble with the hispanic
voters that honestly i don't see how you
can win an election if you lose if you
were at 78 biden with hispanic voters
and now you're at 20 something 30
something that's a tough equation
last word well um when nancy pelosi says
that it's on the ballot well republicans
get to vote too in this election and i
think that and republican enthusiasm may
have been dampened
if this court had not ruled the way that
it did right because of all the work as
katie was saying decades of work that
has gone into
being able to find a case that would
overturn it and the last thing i would
point out is that terry mcauliffe down
in virginia when he was running against
yunkan they tried to make it all about
abortion right and at in the end um
in the exit polls showed that of the
people who thought abortion was the most
important issue 60 percent of them voted
for yunkan
there you go
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else